with data science and why
for for my particular problem for a lot
of movement detection it's okay in my
terms then I'm going to talk about
lateral movement I'm going to explain to
you what is it you don't need any
background in cyber security
I'm going to talk about the challenges
of detecting this specific problem
going to go over some previous work
then I'm going to go in a very very high
level about our algorithm about platma a
little bit about the results and if I
have time about some future work
um and we implemented latma as a free
tool
we presented it uh um in blackhead I saw
someone here that also was in blackhead
so it was very very nice
um okay let's just begin
um so let's talk about data science and
cyber security
in order to solve any problem with data
science you must follow some stages
first
first you need to collect data data
Gathering and in cyber security it it's
usually very very difficult because I
don't know how many of you heard
[Music]
um
uh there were a lot there were a lot of
uh cyber breaches uh uh data set uh in
the last two years even here in Israel
and organizations don't usually want to
share their data because it increases
the chances that someone will steal it
so it's really really hard to obtain
data for cyber security problems
even if you got data you need to
put it somewhere and and before you
analyze it and most of the time you've
got the the data is unstructured
uh for example if you you can look about
processes in your computers uh files
Network traffic and usually you want to
look at all of them together in order to
solve your problem so dealing with
unstructed data is not impossible but it
makes your life a bit difficult
then you need to explore the data and
usually in cyber security problems we
will look for air events
um for uh if for our problem for example
we're looking for specific breach that
occurred uh what are the chances that if
I collect random data I'm going to face
this bridge so I'm going to going to
talk maybe a little bit about how we
deal with those kinds of problems
um then after I explore the data I need
to to build a model A classifier or or
something that's give me the output I
want
and in cyber security we don't have that
many what we call out of the box models
I cannot just apply lstm on on on text
and and get something uh I don't have
any networks the data is usually not
really nice and easy to work with and it
it changes from problem to problem so
it is quite difficult and the last step
is I need to validate the model I built
on data and cyber security problems are
very influenced by Trends so if for
example now I I build a model and I've
validate it on my data in two years it
might be not relevant because hackers
now don't really use lateral movement
but they use something else or a new
product came into the market and it
changes how organization looks uh
yeah so it's really really hard
um but I I have really good conditions
to work on my problem because
um where I work silver for uh we
collected data for four years and
put a lot of uh thought and effort on uh
putting in the right warehouse and and
label it and tag it and
therefore
most of those problems I don't have I
have really good conditions for the for
for solving my problem
and now let's talk about lateral
movement
let's okay
so what is lateral movement lateral
movement is where attackers got somehow
to the organization can be for example
by sending a phishing email and and by
that getting that the initial access to
the organization and then they move they
advance from computer to computer until
they let's call it fulfill their
objectives their objectives might be for
example uh encrypting the entire
organization all the computers uh maybe
leak some information out
can be many things but the thing that
are important to remember about lateral
movement is that uh the attacker the
hacker is advancing from computer to
computer I don't care about how how they
got the access to the organization and I
don't care what their what is their
objective
so let's talk about how hackers or
attackers move in in the organization so
in every organization you have something
that's called identity provider
Microsoft Technology is called active
directory but it's not necessarily it
can be a lot of stuff
and in order to log into your computer
or to move to uh to another computer you
need to provide credentials to this
active directory or identity provider
um credentials might be password might
be a fingerprint image
and if you're validated if the active
directory says that you're validated you
can
advance to the computer you wanted to
reach
and if you're an attacker you can also
infect them with a malware for example
and I think
identifying or detecting lateral
movement is hard because
attackers move exactly like normal users
so if I log into my computer and if
attacker tries to log into my computer
it's going to look exactly the same the
logs on the background is going to be
the same
um I'm not going to see
yeah
yeah so the cyber world is really really
huge and I'm I'm talking about identity
set and and and in general all the world
of identity is a bit more complicated
because you you
attackers don't leave any tracks
when I log in or in other people if if
you stole my my password and you log
into my computer I won't see the
difference
and stuff like that and you have the
frequency stuff like that okay so if you
don't know when you're evaporating
in your entering my account you
see the distribution of the your actions
will be very different than mine
yeah yeah
and thank you for for asking this
question because uh my point is that the
lateral movement detection problem can
be solved only with machine learning or
or anomaly detection I want to try to
understand whether this characteristic
of behavior is mine or someone's else
and the nice thing is it a lateral
movement is advancing between older
computers in the organization so it's
not just logging to my computer I need
to learn how the entire system system
behaves
okay so before I go and tell you about
latma
I want to tell you a little bit about a
previous work
of researchers from Berkeley and
drawbacks that's they did it a year and
a half ago they called their algorithm
Hopper and Hopper is aimed for security
teams stock teams if you know what it is
uh with what we call limited budget so
security
I don't know security analysts
frequently look at alerts
um that they got from from the system
and if they got
a thousand alerts per day they won't be
able to do anything with that so they
have some kind of budget or limit for
the number of alerts they can see and
Hopper get this uh budget as a parameter
and what the algorithm does it finds
somehow the in very like in general a
normal authentication like like you said
and put them on a graph how he does it
so if
um I'm gonna authenticate from computer
a to computer B A and B are going to be
nodes in the graph and the
authentication between those nodes or
are it's going to be it's going to be
the edge
after I'm building this this graph I'm
going to look for suspicious uh passes
and and score them and then I'm going to
alert only on the passes with the uh the
higher scores
quite simple let's see how it works by
the way this uh this image you're going
to see is from their paper paper not not
mine
so the first component is called
scenario measure and it takes uh it it
kind of does the learning it takes on
the main context like what is the roles
of the computers are there workstations
servers proxies whatever
and some historic logins
um like patterns of of logins with which
servers I frequently authenticate Etc
put them on a graph and then look for
passes
then there are three uh type of passes
this algorithm looks uh looks for first
one is called B9 passes and if it's
benign it is not interesting it's not
dangerous and therefore uh deal with in
one throw any alert
second one is called uh clear credential
switch and it means that
there are three computers a b and c I
moved from computer a to computer B and
it was suspicious on computer B uh
I probably stole credentials of someone
else and then I see suspicious assembly
authentications between computer B and
computer C
the third scenario is unclear I have
three computers and I see two enormous
authentications with the same
credentials which means I authenticated
from A to B and then from B to C
and uh the last phase of this algorithm
is throwing the other so we don't throw
any alert on B9 passes if I have a clear
credential switch it means that someone
stole credentials and therefore I am
going to throw alert always and in the
unclear casualty I'm going to give
scores
uh uh to the passes and then just alert
on the highest score according to my
alert budget
was it kind of clear this is not my work
this is previous work
in a very high level
yeah oh
so let's talk a bit about the results of
Hopper
so it was
tested uh
on about billion authentications a
little bit less uh from 15 months of a
Dropbox Enterprise data with some of
simulated lateral movement attacks
and it detects uh 95 of the attacks with
average false positive rate of 9 per day
which is quite good to this time this
was kind of the state of the art
algorithm till this day
however there are some still lies and
and problems with this algorithm
uh first simulated attacks are nothing
like real attacks
um not only for a lot of movement by the
way any lateral movement rate and any
cyber security breach uh
is I don't know it's better to sample
real attack than uh simulate it because
it always difference as I said before
there are some Trends but
yeah that's true
um
that's true
um but I remember I'm reminded that I
have data from of four years
so I'm kind of covered from this
perspective
foreign
no so the logs are the same but from
different time in different
organizations
authentication logs yeah
um another another problematic stuff
that's going on here
um it was trained only on one
organization on Dropbox organization and
different organization uh they have
different characteristics so if I'm
a bank or hospital or cyber insurance or
blumber I'm going to have different
organizations different size different I
don't know different number of computers
with different roles and therefore
learning on specific organization is not
going to yield good results for other
types of organizations
um all these stuff with the alert budget
is kind of a lie I lied to you before
when I said you we have nine false
positive per day because I didn't tell
you what is the alert budget alert
budget naturally limits the number of
alerts you get and therefore if I cannot
throw a lot of alerts I won't have that
many false positives per day so this is
a lie that's our algorithm get gets rid
of
and the last thing that is quite
problematic problematic with this uh
algorithm is that it looks only for
advancing some uh for movement but
lateral movement actually has some other
really interesting patterns that are not
taking into consideration with this
algorithm
and I'm going to show you uh how we do
it later
oldest calling and exciting 27 11 why
not wait for the budget yeah in real
time
it's a great question uh I'm going to
answer that in four slides
um he asked if the algorithm Works in
real time or not and I'm going to
to answer that in in four slides
president
users
right from the company or if you are
assigned to a new project when you need
to access new servers so you cannot
completely rely on tests
yeah that's true so the question was uh
I'll make a chart uh if I take a long
period of of data some Trends might
change over the time and I cannot rely
on all data and it's true the algorithm
learns all the time
and when I'll get to my algorithm it
will be much clearer why uh we are
immune for those kinds of of
uh I don't know of stuff
I have more questions before I go to
latma
clear you go from each merch from
computers yeah
um
if I'm as a developer looking into
physiologic directory
foreign
yeah so um
no I think you understand
um maybe all the questions about uh how
a lot more works there is a really good
slide in in a couple of slides it's
experience really well and I think it's
explained exactly this point
um so I think that's we should wait with
those questions
um
uh now it's also a good question
okay so let's proceed
um so let's talk about what mine about
the research we made
um so like every good research the first
thing we did is Implement Hopper
um and we remove the alert budget we
looked on all the alerts uh on over all
our data and try to understand the
characteristic when what are the scores
um uh how frequent it things are are
alerted and stuff like this
um
uh yeah so I'll say now some of our data
contain real life lateral movement
attacks
um and since we collected data for uh of
four years uh we have
uh not hundreds but we have we have a
lot
we have a lot and and a lot of them are
confirmed with customers so
it is really good and Justified and we
we could work with it
so we kind of apply the following
changes uh to Hopper so first we had
that the first phase uh uh where we
decided which edges or authentications
are including in the graph and which are
not so we tuned a little bit this
scenario major according to what we saw
we add another filter layer that looks
for specific events lateral movement
events and not only advancing from
computer to computer
uh and we change the way we manage
alerts all the alert system is changed
let's see comparison between the two
algorithms so we had a scenario measure
at the beginning and latma also has
scenario measure we call it enhanced
scenario mature because we made some
changes and tuning parameters according
to data we see on many organizations
then next phase is kind of the same uh
don't be angry with me I was kind of
lazy so I didn't draw something from
scratch we don't exactly look for
sequences or passes here but it's close
enough but we remove the alert budget
um then we have our new phase that's
called the event matcher we're looking
for additional events of lateral
movement that might point out that we
are looking at lateral movement
and finally we have after we see a new
event we can decide either to throw
alert not throwing alert or merging the
current event to existing alert
it's going to be very very clear in a
few slides
okay
so let's deep dive a bit to each of
those components so let's talk about the
enhanced scenario measure which is kind
of similar to what Hopper is
um so a few examples for what we do here
we filter out some automation logins so
if for example I login to specific
server exactly every one hour it means
that's probably I'm running a script and
it's probably not an attacker and I can
filter it out from my graph
next what I'm trying to do is to
associate between
users and the computers they own so if I
know that I'm gal on this computer it
means that every authentication I'm
doing from this computer is very likely
to be legitimate
another another thing we do is we're
looking for what we call syncs and hubs
things are computers at a lot of
different users authenticate with and
hubs are the Opposites of our machines
that a lot of different users
authenticate from like vpns or proxies
or whatever
and the reason we filter them out is
because they cause a lot of noise in the
algorithm even if lateral movement
involves them in somehow we will
probably detect them somewhere else
during this process
cool now let's talk about the event
matcher so as I said before the event
matcher we are looking for additional
patterns or event that might point out
that we are looking at lateral movement
if I had more time I would go with you
over a relateral movement and we would
understand those uh kind of events
together but I don't have that much time
so just going to spoiler you what kind
of events we have
yeah
am I okay so we have three types of
events
we have a searching event
um and what we saw is that a lot of time
attackers don't know the organization
they got to a computer and now they need
to know uh they need to look for a new
home or a new computer to advance to so
they're trying to understand uh what's
going on
we have the actual advancing when the uh
when the user Advanced from computer a
to computer B
and we have the acting where the
attacker fulfilling their objective they
can encrypt the entire environment in
this case or looking the information out
uh it can be can you repeat that
acting is when the uh the attacker
fulfilling their objective for example
they can encrypt your entire
organization the computers of the
organization
it's too late it's true
um but it's really easy to detect
true if you want to block lateral
movement in real time the acting is not
very good if you want to detect it even
one day later
it is still good and I agreed searching
is is I think the the most important
pattern or event that wasn't considered
into
uh into Hopper
um so let's just go over those are the
type of the events I'm not going to go
over all the real events but
here are a few examples for so we have a
a searching event that's called white
cane and this is where the attacker
manually tries to find new computer to
advance to they they do it usually
manually because they don't want to be
revealed at this point uh because this
is this is usually happens in the
beginning of lateral movement attacks we
sell a lot of those
um
we have an event that we call it a
bridge and this is actually exactly like
copper we have three computers a b and c
uh we have suspicious authentications
between a and b and then another
suspicious authentication between B and
C with the same credentials
we have switch Bridge which is the same
but uh there was a credential staff at
computer B and usually the the new
credential that were set are stronger
one they have more permissions than the
original user
another interesting things or event we
saw which is actually a combination of
two white canes we call it the way Chief
and this is where the attacker is
looking for a new home
they find one
and then they're looking again
so they shift their weight from the
original computer to the one they found
and now they're performing
um
awaken again
and
the last one is blast and in Blast not
like white cane the uh
attacker they don't care to be revealed
they just going and and accessing a lot
of different machines in the
organizations in a very very short time
usually in order to steal information or
to encrypt the the
computers
is trying to connect to any computer
you're not logging it you cannot know it
is only after you can connect to one of
the filters only then you have the event
of collecting no it's not true uh when
when there is attempt of connecting to
to a computer I also see it
I mean I I didn't uh deep like I didn't
cover all the details of the algorithm
but I see not only successful
authentications but also failed attempts
but you said that you filter out the hap
setups so if it is on we have someone
that you don't know yeah but Hub in Hub
I'm not filtering out when I'm looking
for Hub I'm not filtering out a normal
Authentication
Hub is where you have a lot of
legitimate authentication from a machine
and blast is where you have a lot of
suspicious authentications from your
machine it's not it's not the same it's
similar but not the same okay the last
question because I don't think so once
he tries
when does it query the Adaptive
directory because actually when it comes
back to that is when you know that there
is an attack okay
um so the question was when I query the
active directory so there are two two
answers for this question
um silverford solution we have like a
pattern and and we see all the traffic
to the active directory all the time we
don't need to query
this is what silverport is based on and
we have a free tool not related to
Singapore uh that's uh has a model that
collects all the data and offline tries
to understand if you have lateral
movement attack on your environment from
the last couple of days but if you want
the real-time solution and I answer your
someone's else's question here as well
if you want a real-time solution you
need seal report I don't want to be uh
it's not a marketable presentation
um
another question yeah when you say free
to visit open source uh some of it I'm
going to the last slide is only
uh
cool so now we'll zoom out for the event
matcher and let's talk about the alerts
so basically I'm throwing a new alert
when I see two events that are
connecting there that are connected with
the same computer together so if I have
a
a bridge like a movement from A to B to
C and then on C I'm seeing a white cane
those two events are connected together
so I'll throw a new alert
and if I see a new event that is
connected to existing alert I'm just
going to
um
to match them together to connect them
so now let's just go over all the
algorithm together so I have my
organization
first off I need to collect data
so all the edges here represent
authentication then I filter out
authentication that are not relevant
that are not anomalous
then I'm looking for events
so you can see that I have here a bridge
and here a bridge and here I have a
white cane and finally I'm connecting
the events together like here
let's talk about the results this is the
thing the interesting part
so we tested it on more than 30
different environments actually it's
even more with also almost billion
authentications
um with a couple of free lateral
movement attacks
we detected also about 95 of them
from the one that we are aware of of
course there might be another lot of
movement in the inner data that we're
not aware of uh but
um
we detected absolutely the most of them
and we got a false positive rate uh like
one in three days and not nine per day
which is almost 30 times better than
Hopper and we don't have any alert
budget here
um and as you said before the algorithm
can implement it online or offline
online where the authentications comes
uh in stream one by one and we can
detect the events uh online control
alerts online we can decide whether they
go into the graph or not online
uh by the way it also holds for Hopper
for both algorithms
um now let's talk about the two uh so we
we developed an open source tool
that contains uh two modules uh
one which is really open source that
collect the authentication traffic from
your organization
and one which is free but it's not open
open source that runs the lot more logic
and what the tool yields is a report
with all the uh
lateral movement attacks when they
occurred by whom are in the organization
and uh a JF file that represents a lot
of movement and here you can see for
example that's those green circles are
white canes and here you don't see it
but
there is a blast
um
I think those those results are really
really important because when you work
in in a security team in a if you're a
security analyst you see a lot of alerts
every day and one of your challenges is
convincing your boss that what you're
seeing now is real and we provide the
evidence and not only say this is
lateral Movement we we say we kind of
say why
um
so you're welcome to try it yourself so
the data collection is open source
um if you want to play to run uh latma
you can take the data you collected and
run latma
and if you're looking for a job I'm I'm
specifically recruiting a security
expert to to my team and there are a lot
of other open positions in silverford uh
yeah and now you can ask questions
yes have you been able to
fingerprint specific attackers in case
some attribution yeah so the question
was uh if we were able to figure out
like to characterize specific attackers
and the answer is kind of we saw some
Trends so that the way shift I mentioned
before I decided to put it here because
we saw it a couple of times and if you
think about it it's it's just two white
kinds connected by each other we should
the algorithm should alert on it anyway
but it was too interesting not to
present it
foreign
yes so it's really hard to tell because
each one of them we had a couple that
were we verified with the customers and
they were real uh not all the customers
are very very friendly so it's in some
cases we just guessed
um but I can say and again it's not
marketable but now we're opening a
threat hunting team in silverford
because it works I mean we'll we'll look
we're seeing a lot really a lot of
lateral movements and other stuff
um
yeah so a lot of them are real I'm not
sure that all of them yes
[Music]
over many days or months and they
eventually gradually obtain
authentication data for the system so it
will obviously see the patterns
and then we finally decide
that we have all the whole network maps
and various computers already with their
authentication data so we can perhaps
one thing then
all the things from the search position
to the access issue with someone already
said this story yeah so we are right
um I'll just repeat the question uh you
asked what about uh if attacker or
attacking slowly the the environment if
they're getting access to the
environment and then wait a few weeks or
so and then move on to the next uh uh
the next computer and and so on
and the answer is that yeah we will miss
the attack but certainly most of the
attacks are done by kids they're very we
so usually very high like very I don't
know
the I think the average duration of
lateral movement is about
a couple of days marks
um I don't know how many of you heard
but I think a year and a half or two
years ago there were the Sunburst attack
which was huge and it was sophisticated
and and yeah we might miss attacks like
this I mean
uh this is kind of the future work that
we need to to do with the algorithm
um yeah you're right also
um
[Music]
exposed to the effect anomalous behavior
that is different from federal movements
so we might definitely remember for the
attack
yeah this is shy and Samir there in my
team
and they work also on this algorithm
yeah so we have other techniques to stop
attacks that are not related just to
these algorithms so we kind of
we cover a lot of stuff
yeah more questions
because you are very small data a small
number of labels
yes the the question was uh is it
supervised or not supervised learning so
it kind of both uh we we it's true that
we don't have many labeled attacks but
we started with what we have
and then we kind of discovered more
attacks and we went and asked customers
um
is it the real attack and they told us
oh yeah or it's a it usually was a real
attack or a pen testing which is
simulation of attack but it's kind of
kind of real Attack for our purposes
for those of you who don't know pen
testing is simulation of real attacks in
the environment I know I said it's
cheating but when I I detect it and I
don't didn't know it's it's there I'm
I'm okay with it I mean uh
um I mean I don't do pen testing the the
customers do pen testing and they don't
tell me about it usually
all right okay great thank you very much
thank you